I hope something about yeah what now
that part's over
okay okay so let's reset this about you
I really like this guy yeah that's a
cool know everything now what I
compliment him it's gonna sound weird
so just makes about the story I just see
that it's so I see it [ __ ] weird
I see you're like Kevin profession oh
yeah you're right what's up man dude you
get you can nah man what's up nah you
good - I don't know I'm good yeah bro I
feel great so let me ask you something
wait so when did you decide to do what
you do man I decided when I was I think
like 18 or something
I how how does that happen I was uh I
was a photo assistant for a bit I was
working for like Anthony Mandler and
it's other dude Chris Baldwin and some
other people and I remember the thing
that like stopped me from doing it was I
was on a P Diddy Ciroc commercial and I
never wanted to do commercial stuff yeah
to be behind the camera but uh my dad
had set up this thing where I was
supposed to work next to the director to
just kind of learn and the guy turned me
into a PA and I and what did your dad do
my dad's a doctor so he like traded he
was he was helping his his sister and
giving her medical advice and and
medicine and then he was like here take
my son and teach him oh wow and and then
he kind of he [ __ ] me off and like put
me as a PA and I was like dude I could
go on Craigslist and get a PA job pretty
[ __ ] yeah yeah and then so after 24
hours on a P Diddy Ciroc commercial that
we had to do for I think 24 more and
they were like spending way too much
money on it I quit do this and then I
kind of just I took some time off and
and then that's I started getting into
music from my friend Eamon and then from
there like I heard Russ goes music and
that's not so on and so forth I moved to
Atlanta I'm just gonna I'm gonna I don't
want no because my few hands you want
the full I'll tell you why because my
fans probably don't know much and I want
them to know everything okay so I moved
my friend Cory Nita was working for
Dallas Austin at the time and I
was dating this girl Willa Holland and I
knew was she hot yeah she was on The OC
I got way hotter go I was famous Wow now
I don't get any girls at all that's not
true at all
oh no but I mean I got I was uh I was
with her for a bit but how did she like
you I mean she didn't like me that much
because she left to New York City and
ended up doing heroin and never calling
me again and that is legitimately what
happen was that after the OC then that
was after the Oh she okay yeah she she
was like hey I'm gonna I'm gonna New
York to shoot a show and then like I
kept calling her and you know a couple
days go by she would answer one time
then a couple more days ago by she would
answer one more time and then dead
silence and I remember calling after two
weeks and be like hey haven't heard from
you it was established that you guys
were dating then it was I was it yeah
yeah that's crazy yeah you were
heartbroken yeah yeah definitely
what oh yeah really but this this girl
she she she rebounded me pretty well and
then and then we'll Achaemenid me being
like and i was wasted and I yelled very
loud oh wow Lana felt good no no this is
a no way in LA but yeah I moved to
Atlanta for two months uh-huh and was
working there for Corey and I was
sleeping on his kitchen floor on a
blow-up mattress for two months and then
I moved back to LA after that after I
learned a bit and I'd remembered a track
he when he was when he was learning how
to DJ he like stayed in his basement for
I forget I think it was like two years
or something and and did 10,000 hours
worth of work on trying to become a DJ
so I was like alright 10,000 hours is
like that if you booked you'll become a
master at something if you put that much
work in that's true though yeah what
hundreds I'm true so I just sat in my
back house and I told my parents was
like look let me take school off for a
year if I make nothing
happen I will go back to college if I do
then that's what I'm doing yeah yeah and
then and your parents were like cool
with it they're like I don't like that
idea but fine try it and oh they were 50
and 50 out they were like it doesn't
matter he is a lot he's a lot yeah yeah
fifty is a lot they were great no no I
mean my mom was trying to sleep certain
days and I'm making like like I'm making
like fart noises on my computer Wow like
air horn farts okay Wow Wow
yeah you don't want to hear that yeah I
do so your did a year of that huh yeah
just sat in my in my back house kind of
I didn't talk to anybody really I like I
hung out with a couple people but it was
you know Wow and then what well then
what do you do after that you could you
do you do obviously shows I know I
wasn't doing any shows yet I know but
are you doing like such beginning times
of DJing yeah where you would find all
your music on a hype machine and and my
main goal was to play Steve Aoki's Club
Cinna space that was it that was really
like the main goal was like alright I
need to play music or I need to make
music to be able to play in that Club
with Steve Aoki Steve Aoki is a DJ yeah
kidding yoky used to have a club yet
since that was his yeah yeah I remember
some space yeah yeah and so he would do
all those now he was already big then he
wasn't as big as he is now yeah I mean
he was he was big enough to have his own
night there yeah what could just say it
another thing about DJ is that every I
mean I it's really not my world but
every time I run into them they're
probably the nicest people I've ever
[ __ ] man in my life like I was in
Atlanta who does nerdy dudes and I ran
it I was in the lobby I hotel lobby and
that's this long-haired Asian guys just
running after me Steve Aoki it's the
abaya I didn't know I thought was just
like some crazy like Jesus looking on
Asian guy because me Steve Aoki and he
picks me up and he starts running around
with me in his hand
Brian I got this I know we and I go this
is nice guys we took a photo and stuff
but I would like and and I when I met
you I think you're the only two have met
but the two nice
sighs pretty nice well if I met let me
say this if I met the first two comics I
met I would say that they were the worst
people in the world and I would have
quit okay I mean I think it's very
important to when you meet people in a
field that they're like the nicest
people because if I met two dicks right
first and then I he might not even be
here but can i things are very
interesting why I've always tried to
figure out why they're the angriest
people ever and it's because you just
have to keep making fun of the world
always so I feel like after you keep
doing that for a while you start really
believing you think I'm angry no no
you're you're not you're definitely
different ones yeah but never in like a
super real way there's certain ones that
get really really angry I think I know I
know why and it's the same reason why
I'm angrier today than I ever was is
because you keep growing up when you're
younger everything makes you laugh yeah
and then you get inundated with so much
like good comedy yeah especially because
I live with a comedian that nothing
makes me laugh anymore my standard for
being for having a giggle is so high
that when someone just even like dad
jokes irritate me yeah anger me no no I
mean dude when I look up at the stars
I'm like [ __ ] that dude I've seen that
for 30 years yeah there's some other
[ __ ] cool [ __ ] yeah asteroids flying
yeah yeah I want to go wow I bright the
sky that is exactly space that's exactly
what happens
[Music]